hey what's going on in spill pur and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
for Monday March 19th dude I'm in a
great mood boo boo you [ __ ] suck my
[ __ ] dick boo boo Pope I'm gonna I
don't know why I just sang that song I
just been watching a bunch of [ __ ]
old you know I listen to old country now
and then I started listening to old
[ __ ] rock and roll
you know what's-his-face just died the
guy used to [ __ ] film chicks that he
[ __ ] on or something whatever his name
is Chuck Berry uh-huh whoa dead you know
it's part of one of his classics if you
listen to the background a game [ __ ]
on people I have such respect for him
too you know it's just once stuff like
that gets out once it gets out anyway so
I just been I'm in a great [ __ ] mood
because my [ __ ] I had this rotator
cuff injury and it's just been [ __ ]
with me since October and I finally
found an exercise it works for me for me
I just feel like for my shoulder my
shoulder needs a safe place a lot of
crying out there all right so this is
this is the exercise if you if your
rotator cuff is [ __ ] up like mine is
the problem is is if you can look with
this injury it's like you can still pick
up the same amount of weight you can
always pick up depending on the angle
but then shaking hands or just reaching
for a salt shaker all of a sudden you
like this sharp pain it's basically what
I've learned is it's the muscle like
it's when you first go to raise your arm
that first 30 degrees that's what the
[ __ ] it is and then the big boys take
over whatever you're doing how you
lifting your lunch pail up maybe you got
a giant [ __ ] doughnut you want to
shove it to your face like I did today I
broke my rules about Donuts you know my
my wife
was wanting some doughnuts so I went by
there's a Dunkin Donuts out here right
so I show up and it's late in the day
it's like [ __ ] 2:00 in the afternoon
so all the donuts are gone you know
they're still making them but they don't
have you know they don't have that
freshness to him they got those you know
the little munchkins they like the worst
flavors left it was like blueberry
custard and [ __ ] your mother whatever
the [ __ ] it was called and I was like
that's what you got left they were like
yeah I think I left this after the
people in front of me could not make up
their mind you know can I can we get a
dozen donuts and they lay him down now
that's how long it's been since I've
seen anybody get a dozen donuts they lay
them down back in the day they stood him
up and the frosted from one donut got on
another donut you know and evidently
with all the iphones coming out if
somebody finally decided why don't we
make the Box a different shape and we'll
lay him down and I imagine the Steve
Jobs of Dunkin Donuts went to some sort
of comic-con of fat people and he came
out in a turtleneck sweater with his
[ __ ] New Balance sneakers and he
[ __ ] showed off the the box and
everybody went oh my god right that
[ __ ] man tits bouncing up and down
and you think he gave credit to the poor
little [ __ ] eight-year-old in the
back room well had to put those things
together huh
the blind nine year old girl who [ __ ]
designed the box down and [ __ ] East
Albuquerque you think he gave him any
credit course he didn't
of course he didn't oh look who's here
of my two angels cutie number one and
cutie number two what's up buddy hey Mia
this is some bad language and if she
can't understand it anyways what's going
on do you want to be on the podcast Nene
we'll grab a mic
kukuku you shake my nerve and you rat on
my brain yeah you got to grab stuff in
the bag anyway so what do you mean what
did I do
I know I know come back come back in a
minute
come back in a minute I'm in the middle
of this story all right okay bye cutie
you know that [ __ ] guy a little time
to make the donuts I was just an actor
so anyway so I call up Mia okay
and I just go yeah they don't have any
[ __ ] donuts that they're donuts up
there anyways and she went oh my god she
goes blasphemy a guy from Boston which
I'm not I'm from the Boston area I'm
from the safe suburbs all right so he
can take you Good Will Hunting [ __ ]
quotes and I tell him to somebody else
cuz I grew up in a nice suburb there was
there was cul-de-sacs
we played street hockey we roasted
marshmallows alright there was no it's
not your fault there was none of that
[ __ ] nobody liked apples and I sucked at
math okay that's it I climb trees and I
had a paper route okay so enough with
the Southeast [ __ ] anybody if every from
Massachusetts is not from South Boston
we didn't steal cars okay a lot of us
are from the suburbs
we slept in bunk beds I'm so sick of
that [ __ ] movie where you from you
just you just say you know from
Massachusetts out thee did you grow up
in Southie did you like apples did you
say how about them apples down at the
tasty like some [ __ ] stuck-up harvard
[ __ ] is gonna mess with anybody ever
from [ __ ] swell back to a South
Boston used to be now they're all
Harvard grads that live down there from
what I've heard I have no idea I don't
know what goes on in that city okay last
time I lived there they were just
starting the big dick and that big ugly
green thing was still there and going
from Fanueil Hall over to the north end
you took your life in your hands you
just felt it he went underneath the
[ __ ] southeast expressway and it was
scary you know anyways what the [ __ ] am
I so I call her up but I just say yeah I
got that don't it suck and she goes oh
my god she goes a Boston guy saying
Dunkin Donuts sucks that's blasphemy
it's like Mia nobody gives a [ __ ] about
their doughnuts it's all about the
coffee all right
I don't drink the coffee I don't drink
coffee I don't like it it tastes like
dirty water it burns my tongue it stains
your teeth it's just it's a [ __ ] it's
trifecta of you know I guess it helps
you take a [ __ ] though I know a lot of
people like you know I drinkin coffee
smoke a cig take a good [ __ ] get on with
my day you know have a French [ __ ]
it's all about the cup like their bread
and butters the coffee okay that's the
lead singer that's like if if Dunkin
Donuts broke up and the coffee went solo
alright that's the George Michael and
the donuts are the the the whatever that
other guy's name was Andrew Ridgeley
anyway so I go yeah [ __ ] that place so
the PO and the people in front of me
they couldn't make up their goddamn mind
like what do you want uh what's in those
oh can we get to it
let's get three of those they kept
talking to each other we'll get three of
the pink ones and I was already having a
bad day cuz I keep my truck in storage
now cuz we got the little one it's just
easier for my wife to get in and out of
the garage and I knew if I kept my truck
there and show he's had to squeeze by it
and try and get the [ __ ] stroller and
all that [ __ ] you know what's gonna
happen eventually she's gonna be like I
don't know what do we need three cars
for and eventually she's gonna make me
sell it so I did a preemptive strike and
I immediately put it in [ __ ] storage
before she could [ __ ] about it so I had
it over the last [ __ ] like five days
lovin so I just switch out alright
I put Jackie and storage and I take out
the old girl right I drove her for like
five [ __ ] days of course the battery
died because I forgot to unhook the the
terminals there I had to get a jump down
at the Comedy Store and anyway so I'm
going to return the car today and it's
the day before I go in the road so we
have a rule in my house in my house
there is a rule that basically the day
before I go on the road I bits family
there hang out you know I make breakfast
I made some [ __ ] meatballs that
cooked the goddamn chicken I make sure
she's got food in the fridge
you know I'm a hell
so I make sure she's gonna be alright
right so I go I got to return my truck
she's like be back I'm like I'm gonna be
back so alright so I get in the truck
and I do what I always do I Drive down
the [ __ ] I gotta move [ __ ] you know I
gotta move her car I've become like a
valet because I have the shittiest
driveway ever right so I'm [ __ ]
driving up the street and as always big
stupid grin on my face it's my favorite
thing ever it's three on the tree it's
so much fun to drive and whenever I get
a little bit of space out here I just
get the [ __ ] run through all three
gears that's all I want to do every time
I do I get bright I'm on a second I get
it into third gear always have the
window down even though I put some AC in
there I never [ __ ] you I didn't use
it for so long I turned it on all this
white [ __ ] came out and I breathed it in
and probably took like [ __ ] nine
years off my life anytime I get it up
into third gear and I'm cruising down
the street I always do the same thing
always go well every time I never did
that once in nine years owner my Prius
ever it's just it's the greatest sound
in the [ __ ] world it's the sound of a
big [ __ ] American engine maybe
running through the [ __ ] gears loud
pipes it's the greatest [ __ ] sound
ever and every time I get to the street
right so I'm having a great time you
know I'm driving down the street I got
the AM radio one I usually listen to
Keyshawn Johnson's [ __ ] Sports Show
but you know it's the weekend so it
wasn't on and anyways I get on to you
know get onto the [ __ ] highway and of
course I'm cruising along and right
before we get to I get to my exit it is
just like this traffic from [ __ ] it's
like 5:00 in the afternoon traffic of a
[ __ ] truck jackknifed it is just of
course my exit and I told the people I'd
be over there by noon so I'm starting to
feel stress I'm like what the [ __ ] is
going on so I try to make a [ __ ] you
know a bust and move here right even
though I'm from the suburbs
Massachusetts move I'm gonna go around
all this [ __ ]
act like I'm gonna drive by and then I'm
gonna [ __ ] cut it and I don't know
what the [ __ ] was going on I couldn't
see any
any accident so I'm trying to go from
one highway to another so I guy I know
what I'll do I'll just [ __ ] rather
than go east like I want to I'll just
get on the west side I'll take the
highway West go down one exit and then
I'll curl back around because I can see
on the overpass there's no [ __ ]
traffic I don't know whether it was like
this offshoot to the on-ramp right that
everyone was going down like I don't
know what that like Paul Simon was doing
like a free concert or some [ __ ] that
was the level of traffic so I say [ __ ]
it I get out of the traffic I Drive down
get it up to third gear right I [ __ ]
go to go west to turn one [ __ ] block
you know want one exit up and then come
back around and as I [ __ ] go there
all of a sudden this is all this other
traffic going the other direction and
I'll and it's the first time since I
started meditating that I had an
absolute meltdown
I literally screamed as loud as I
possibly could [ __ ] you LA every [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] can't [ __ ] in
every word you could possibly think you
know and then I'm [ __ ] just stuck an
even worse traffic going the other way
to go one [ __ ] exit you know up to
come back around and all I'm thinking is
where the [ __ ] I would be if I just just
took the pain to begin with and just
stayed in that traffic jam I'd be
creeping forward and whatever why didn't
I just call the place to say I was gonna
be a little late oh you know what bill
cuz that would have been the chill thing
to do right I did so it turns out I look
up I'm like what the this is like it's
Saturday at noon how was that five
o'clock in the afternoon on Friday
traffic I am like literally beside
myself just saying every curse I
possibly can and I look up and there's
two little flashes going on and it's tow
truck flashers right and I'm like oh
here we go
hey this is all rubbernecking and on the
other side of the road it's [ __ ]
going you know like gangbusters
everybody's cruising by that's where I
want to be right I can't get to it
so I'm like you [ __ ] [ __ ]
rubbernecking pieces what somebody
changing a tire it's gonna be a fender
bender and I'm losing my [ __ ] out there
if I was a [ __ ] dictator
I would deliberately have a car on the
side of the road changing a tire who
never slowed down and looked at it would
be eliminated would be removed from
society thread to the [ __ ] pigs
whatever the hell is whatever that fat
[ __ ] in North Korea does there was
goddamn relatives feeds him to dogs
that's what I would do I was actually I
was so [ __ ] mad I was like you know
that fat [ __ ] in North Korea he's
actually making sense to me
you know so I get all the way up I
should be careful man he might send
somebody over here to missed me
like he did to his other you know we set
up those two [ __ ] [ __ ] over there
right to take out his [ __ ]
stepbrother so anyways I get all the way
up to the traffic jam and of course it's
a little fender bender there's people
standing there there's nothing going on
but I'm finally gonna get past it
finally gonna get off the exit come
around and [ __ ] run through the gears
and [ __ ] go down the other side and
what do I see on the other side of the
road where it was all nice and clear now
there's major traffic because the dumb
[ __ ] on the other side of the highway
are slowing down to look at the [ __ ] on
my side of the highway so now I got to
sit through it [ __ ] twice and
something told me don't get off at the
first exit bill everybody has this idea
go to the second exit and you know and
then come back and guess what I did I
ignored that instinct got off the first
one bump up a bomb [ __ ] dead stop
traffic and the only way to get back on
the highways I got to make this illegal
u-turn and I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
making it and I'm just sitting there
[ __ ] [ __ ] dictator
[ __ ] cut all their [ __ ] heads off
and I'm getting ready to make my illegal
u-turn and I just happen to look at my
rear rear view mirror and guess what's
two cars behind me a [ __ ] cop I'm
like what are the [ __ ] odds now I got
to go stray said [ __ ] this so I get in
the right lane and I just cruise up and
I get out of his sight I finally [ __ ]
turn around
I got no I finally got into a good lane
and I came back and then I got back on
it under traffic again looked at the
same people looking at the same accident
there was nothing going on and then I
[ __ ] finally was able to continue on
and of course they made the call there
was no problem no but he gave his [ __ ]
nobody yelled at me it was fine I
completely lost my [ __ ] and I'm a baby I
got so [ __ ] mad that when I saw the
people on the other side of the road
rubbernecking I gave them the finger
then I was all the way to the right
getting off the highway and I gave all
of them family like do you realize how
immature that is I mean I was just like
have you ever been embarrassed about
yourself by yourself like I actually hit
that level cuz like I stuck my whole
[ __ ] arm out the window giving him
the finger the person behind me could
see it'd be like who's this guy giving
the finger to you know I'm basically
saying it wasn't one of my best moments
but anyways as I mentioned earlier I one
of the great things is I somebody show
me this exercise for rehabbing the
rotator cuff and it's [ __ ] been great
first of all what you do is you
basically you bend over at the waist no
you're not gonna take it up the ass
okay before anybody makes that easy joke
you let your arm hang down and then what
you start doing
it's basically your finger you hope your
fingers are pointed at the floor your
arms hanging straight down you just make
small circles right and counterclockwise
or clockwise and then you just start to
make it bigger and bigger chesty yes get
to the point of pain and then you live
there for a minute then you back it back
down to small circles and then go
clockwise if you want counterclockwise
you just go vice versa you just go the
other direction you do the same thing
again whatever that does it kind of gets
some [ __ ] I don't Lube in there I
have no idea I don't know [ __ ] about
Anatomy and right and anyways and then
what you do is you have your arm
straight out not straight up you have it
down an angle you walk up to a wall
alright I have to explain this part
perfectly alright and by the way you're
at your own risk on this one
you have your arm probably at like a
whatever 15 degree angle you're standing
right next to the wall sideways okay is
that perpendicular to the wall I have no
[ __ ] idea all right it's like just
imagine the wall was your friend and the
two of you went to a general admission
concert and he got there early just
imagine what the space would be between
the two of you but you'll be both
looking at the same [ __ ] right it still
doesn't make sense perpendicularly the
[ __ ] thing alright then you pick so
you reach out you touch the wall alright
your arms at a 15 degree angle and then
you just slowly start walking it up and
obviously as it gets more straight
you're gonna have to move your body
further away from the wall and you just
walk it up with your fingers so it's
basically it's the weight of your arm
but your fingers are taken away most of
the weight and walk it all the [ __ ]
way up until it's like you know the
answer in a classroom and you're so
excited and you're straight up and then
you walk it back down you do a set of
three to five and I did it I've been
doing it twice a day and my [ __ ]
shoulders amazing and then I iced it
afterwards and it feels [ __ ] amazing
I actually sat down played a little
drums today it was [ __ ] phenomenal
and I don't know maybe that maybe
somebody can explain it a little bit
better maybe there's a YouTube video of
it I don't know so anyways that's what
I've been doing and I feel great and the
guy who is basically keeping my dog for
the rest of her life
so I know she'll be safe was in town and
he brought her by and I got to take her
on a couple of hikes we hung out and you
know it's sort of like a shared custody
thing I mean he has her like 95% of the
time but I know she's safe she looked
great and it's awesome I don't know I
don't know if it's good or bad for me to
keep seeing her because it's always
[ __ ] unbelievably sad every time when
I give her back but as long as I know
the next time I'm going to see her then
I kind of have hope or whatever I just
keep jokingly say that she went to
college and this is like spring break
you know she comes back in March or
whatever but but it's it you know what's
great is I know she's okay I
no she's gonna live out a full life and
you know whenever that day comes when
she's coming down to the end of it I'm
gonna be there cuz I always I kind of
made a promise you know you know when
you get a dog that's like you know
that's it like how much you love a dog
it's like dude I'm there until the end
and you know even though the way it
worked out with having a kid and
everything the the main point of the
whole thing was that she survived and
she had a great life and she's got this
you know she's living in a great house
now in Arizona and all that type of [ __ ]
and it just means I'll play Arizona more
and the person who owns it makes
frequent trips out here always drives
out and I think he'll always bring her
because he knows that we love her Nia
got to see her and everything she came
back over the house was hanging out and
you know she met smelt like us so she
was cool but it really was never my god
I just said a [ __ ] name I just outed
her name anyways and she just basically
you know it was never about the kid it
was about everybody else that was going
to be coming by and it was gonna be too
crazy and the dog was gonna get even
more protective and you know I went
through with the whole trainer it was
like the dogs gonna go to a whole nother
level and I just knew something
something was gonna happen
the craziness they having a kid so we
just we made the right decision
anyways all right where do we go from
here
I'm gonna edit that out by the way
that's gonna know you guys you said you
live whose book we know so many weird I
was out there so many weirdos so anyways
what have I been up to I've been
watching a little bit of the match as
much as I can you know having the kiddo
around
I watched Duke you know win their first
round
I don't know I'm assuming they won the
second round alright I would have
assumed that they're in the [ __ ]
Sweet sixteen my internet sucks right
now you know that is such a [ __ ] I I
went I spent all this [ __ ] money I
was just like dude you give me [ __ ]
the Internet that Jesus would have
they said all right it's gonna be 9
million bucks I said I'll write that
[ __ ] check you you [ __ ] criminal
and they said fine and I had the best
internet for about six months and then
slowly it just starts sucking again and
what it is is I think they just turned
the juice up on your house whoever's
paying the most for it and then the next
guy gets bumped back and then he's like
hey what the [ __ ] happened am I good
Internet well you know we upgrade but
but then he plays whoever pays more than
me
see I haven't gone back to them in like
two years and now like I can't even get
I get Internet and like two rooms of my
house and the rest of it sucks let's see
if I can look this up
March Madness there we go here we go
here we go CBS Sports what's going on
come on this is like you're rooting for
the slowest horse ever now come on load
oh my god it worked
and it worked March Madness 2017 live
tournament scores update ba ba ba ba ba
where's the [ __ ] bracket Kansas is
the team we expected I love Kansas I
love camp always I don't know why I've
always loved Kansas I like Duke UCLA
it's [ __ ] fun to see them just
because they're such a legendary
franchise Syracuse exchange plan plans
to extend Boeheim I don't see me how to
watch Duke versus Carolina what the
number two Blue Devils will take on
numbers fell down the number seven Oh
South Carolina and not North Carolina
when the [ __ ] are they doing that I
gotta watch all the Duke games get get
taped but next year I think I'm gonna
add to my sports package and I want to
watch as many of the Duke games in
Kansas I don't know why I've always
loved Kansas and Duke I got into because
I got a couple friends that went there
and then I went to a game and they
treated us great so like that way what
it's over I got to call in Coach K show
it's all wait a second did they lose
into the second half
what the [ __ ] game can't speed him
no 88-81 get the [ __ ] out of here
no [ __ ] way no [ __ ] way
Duke score I just spelled scores
Duke score
no [ __ ] way big Jesus Christ
South Carolina scored 65 [ __ ] points
in the second half they scored 23 in the
first half
Duke scored 30 and 51 oh man I mean I
knew I knew that they didn't have the
team this year but [ __ ] I thought they'd
at least get to the sweet 16 well I hope
that Jason Tatum guy doesn't be [ __ ]
one and done I hope he comes back and I
like that Luke Canard kid you know
Grayson Allen he am too coming off the
bench really well you think you know
with all that [ __ ] I wanted to be hated
you think he'd be a you think he
powdered you think it would pop but he
didn't he he was a [ __ ] man about it
alright well congratulations to South
Carolina
Jesus Christ I know a lot of Duke haters
out there loved listening that in real
time me discovering that they [ __ ]
lost goddamnit all right I'm Kansas
that's my team Kansas Jayhawks I respect
all the men I really don't like you know
I come from a pro sports town so I don't
really have any sort of hatred for
anybody you know what I mean I don't
even hate the [ __ ] North Carolina I
don't I don't even [ __ ] hate him I
don't hate NC State I just like I love
how the tradition of all that how you
know I can sit back I might just I
picked the [ __ ] team so I can
actually get involved in it I guess so
anyways I'll root for Kansas the rest
the way out and I also like seeing UCLA
do well and of course any any [ __ ]
underdog I was I was watching North West
and it sucked watching them loose did
they look they lost them
they came back two against the
Gonzaga who I'm so old to me they're
still the new kids in town even though
they've been crushing it for almost
[ __ ] two decades at this point
anyways let's get back to the podcast
let's get back that may be something
bill that you sort of know about how
about that so anyways I was listening to
all this [ __ ] old rock-and-roll [ __ ]
you know and of course if he listed all
that [ __ ] you're eventually gonna run
into Buddy Holly and I wasn't that Peggy
Sue and I always loved the drums on that
and I never knew what the [ __ ] the guy
was doing I guess he was just playing
paradiddles that guy Jerry Allison I
just love the way he plays on that
[ __ ] song she's playing paradiddles
around the kid he's got the snares off
and I love about wherever the music's
going if it's you know just playing
those basic ones at two chords I don't
know [ __ ] about guitar the brighter
chord he's up on the higher note or
whatever he's on the higher Tom and then
he goes to the floor Tom then occasions
it goes back to the snare it's just a
[ __ ] beautiful piece of music you
know and I'm learning this [ __ ] right
now
with my drum teacher about how to
finally get my paradiddles and [ __ ] and
playing singles and doubles going in and
out getting them up to speed while being
totally relaxed and letting the stick do
the work and it's the hardest
[ __ ] thing in the world because
you already can play it up to a certain
speed just your own [ __ ] up technique
way to just say [ __ ] all of that and
drop like a hundred bpms you know and
start all over again is is a [ __ ] but
if if you stick with it it gets like I'm
not gonna let it gets pretty [ __ ]
exciting where all of a sudden it's just
like wow I don't even feel like I'm
exerting any effort whatsoever and I'm
like three-quarters up to what used to
be my full speed I don't know it's
exciting [ __ ] so by the way you know now
that I got the kid oh my lovely daughter
who every time I think I can't I'm not
going to like you don't think the loves
can go any further they develop more and
more of their personality comes out here
like
oh my god she does that and it just goes
to a whole level like now she's smiling
like he can't believe and the other day
I was sitting there I was with her and
diapers clean she's got a full belly I'm
holding her I'm doing all this [ __ ] that
usually stops her from crying and she's
just being cranky and crying I was just
like what the [ __ ] could this possibly
be and it's my favorite part about being
a parent right now he's trying to figure
out the the riddle like what's going on
with her and you know when I figured out
for all you guys with newborns you know
that it's starting to develop out there
you know what I figured out I was like
she's [ __ ] bored I'm doing the same
[ __ ] and this [ __ ] was interesting for
about a week to ten days and now she's
over it because she's hit a new level of
consciousness you know she can see a
little bit better whatever here a little
bit better she's starting to understand
all those are my feet you know she needs
something else so you know we do like
this tummy time think trying to get her
to pick up her head and learn how to
crawl and stuff so I brought her over to
the little pad thing and it's this
little thing that's got like you know
these little you know rattles and [ __ ]
hanging down for me
and I just turned her over onto her back
and I had a look at those things and she
just looked up and was completely
enamored with them and like that's the
new thing now I put her on her back when
she looks at him she smiles and I'm like
they're they're her friends and this is
the greatest thing ever
because up until now I've had to carry
around like a kettlebell everywhere I
went and was you know messing with my
shoulder and [ __ ] but you know you love
you kids see like [ __ ] the shoulder the
shoulder comes I distant you know xx in
this race you know the first 19 spots of
my daughter right so now what's great is
I can just bring that tummy time thing
into where I'm watching sports I put her
on her back she's looking at the [ __ ]
her friends hanging and I can sit on the
couch and keep that thing moving with my
bass drum foot right as I'm watching as
I'm watching the games it's like the
greatest thing ever I watched like a
whole first half of Northwestern Gonzaga
I just sitting there doing that
it's the greatest thing ever so if you
got a kid that's crying out there and
the diapers clean and they're there
they're falling all that maybe they're
just bored try something new some new
stimulus oh I'm so psyched it's such a
luxury to not have to be holding our air
ball every five seconds you know what I
mean because they're like these little
[ __ ] kettlebells and they'll hold
their hot as hell they're like this hot
water bottle you know they're getting
all hot you're getting all [ __ ] it's
just awful it's like you see it's like
you're stuck in a crowded elevator yeah
I feel like I'm going through menopause
it's like the [ __ ] hot flashes here
that's flashes anyways so let's do let's
do a little bit of uh let me read some
of the advertising hair everybody the
the advertisement what am i doing that
just I just open the maps why would I do
that
all right Oh dirty lemon you know I
finally tried some of this stuff it
takes a second kind of tastes like [ __ ]
a little bit with a little lemon because
it's got the [ __ ] shackle in there
but once you drink it you know it's
alright but it also says on the side of
the bottle this has not been tested or
approved by the Food Drug Administration
so it's kind of like what the [ __ ] am I
putting in my body to be honest with you
but you know here's their advertising
just being honest dirty lemon everybody
evidently I've been seeing these striped
dirty lemon bottles everywhere I haven't
and now I have them in my fridge I do
dirty lemon is a functional beverage
brand with products with optimized
various areas of your life like vitamin
water but without the added colors /
sugar plus the products actually work
well maybe that's why it tastes like
[ __ ] they took the sugar out of it there
are three types now sleep detox skin
plus hair Jesus I need the last ones
like a [ __ ] I needed this ten years
ago and each one contains the juice of
one lemon no sugar is blended with
functional ingredients that actually
work their sleep drink for example
includes magnesium rose water chamomile
and passionflower
all which helped no wonder it tastes
I'm drinking flowers here which helps
you fall asleep fast and stay asleep
through the night evidently I drank one
the other night before bed and had crazy
dreams talk about the dreams so these
guys are weird I didn't drink this [ __ ]
I don't drink some that makes me have
crazy dreams you know that I'm gonna
have a crazy [ __ ] dream and the detox
is secretly is a secretly great hangover
cure drink a bottle and the activated
charcoal absorbs toxins in your body
great after a long night out alright no
[ __ ] I could have used that the I should
have drank that today you know I know I
said I was gonna stop boozing but I got
a problem so I drank the other night but
I cut the booze way down way too [ __ ]
down you know what I mean like when
you're facing somebody out of your life
but they're kind of a psycho you get you
can't do it abruptly you gotta kind of
AE
so it'll waltz them over to somebody
else alright call to action the best
part about dirty lemon is that there's
only one way to order is via text
message you'll never find it in stores
to order go to dirty lemon com register
your mobile number then send them a text
message say hello to a real human and a
few texts after a few texts a six-pack
is sent to your door in one to two days
once you buy via text you'll never want
to go back well if they're not in stores
how the [ __ ] am i seeing them everywhere
you know Jesus when you text them
mention you've heard about them on my
podcast and they'll throw in an extra
case of the sleep drink for free with
your first order twelve bottles for the
price of six for more info check out
dirty lemon com dirty le mo and.com and
text them bill burr sent you to claim
your special offer all right oh [ __ ]
photo tote me on days me undies I'm
wearing them right [ __ ] now do do do
do me on DS me undies I had a donut now
I'm a cow my [ __ ] man tits hanging
lower than my balls
I got saggy thighs and that's not all
about my balls are safe and they're nice
and company with this [ __ ] polka dot
print here I got black and white polka
dot print right now now this is
you know you know what it reminded me of
it reminded me it's one of the jerseys
that when you win a stage in the Tour de
France total frost Tour de France jersey
color meaning here we go let's see what
does the Polka does that the fast one
what is the other yellow is you're the
leader for chrissake what are the
different jerseys mean what do they mean
this is still part of the advertising
just [ __ ] hang in there all right the
different Tour de France jerseys you
know what thanks for nothing you [ __ ]
what is this clickbait oh it's the
Christian Science Monitor huh
I gotta learn about Jesus to find out
what that me our Tour de France jerseys
it's still the same page cycling jersey
okay all right where's the polka dot one
oh it's red polka dot what does that one
mean red polka dot Jersey means oh you
went up the mountain you the fastest
[ __ ] on the mountain all right
well you know there you go that's what
that means anyways elevate your
underwear game to the next level with me
undies you've perfected your wardrobe
but what about the stuff not everybody
gets to see you if you've been settling
for store-bought underwear five packs I
have something that will change your
life for the better me undies what's the
first thing you put on the last thing
you take off don't say your socks you
[ __ ] weirdo
it's your underwear make the most to
make your most important piece of
clothing the best it can be with me
undies what is me undies oh just
seriously soft feel good
undies delivered right to your door do
you think you could have a [ __ ] fight
to the death naked do you think you
would think I would be so self-conscious
that my junk was hanging out like if you
fought he runned away you'd be fine
because you feel like it that it's
covered up psychologically it's covered
up you know what I mean
but I mean despite the fact that if
somebody needs you in the balls even if
you had on [ __ ] you know Jay Leno
[ __ ] dad jeans
it's
gonna hurt just pretty much just the
same but even if you have [ __ ]
underwear I'm still gonna hurt but
psychologically if you fought naked I
don't think you could do it you know to
me it takes a special someone to just be
like yeah you know you know what it is
it's those guys that get hookers that I
already let them kick them in the balls
you ever seen those guys if you ever
seen those [ __ ] porno videos I have
they just booed and right in the balls
it's one of the funniest things you're
ever gonna watch I don't know I vote for
that funniest porn out there is that a
subset of comedy funniest porn I would
say that and then those ones were the
girls like make the choking sound on the
dick you know if the guys banging her
and he's just like there's no way
there's no way to not just burst out
laughing I mean it's like Three Stooges
like Shemp couldn't make a funny noise
than that anyways if you've been
settling for store-bought under way what
the [ __ ] my time what me what is me
undies you might ask
oh just seriously soft feel-good undies
delivered right to your front door hey
how do you know if the person next to
you is who lives next door to you is his
shooting porn how do you know because
you'll be laying there in the afternoon
and all of a sudden you just hear from
the other side of your driveway the
unnies are designed in LA and made from
sustainably sourced micro motile modal
fabric three times softer than cotton B
undies softer than soft luxury undies
comes in an ever-changing selection of
classic colors bold shapes I mean
there's only one way I mean will people
only shape so many different ways and
adventurous patterns so you can tailor
your undies to your own personal style
and guess what you can save time and
money each month with a monthly
subscription as always how much do you
[ __ ] yourself that you got to get
underwear every month if you're not
ready for a subscription that's ok you
can still save that's because my undies
is offering 20% off your first pair just
use our special URL me undies comm slash
burn and get 20% off your first pair so
go ahead revamp your underwear drawer
you deserve it there once again that's
my undies dot-com slash burn me undies
calm / burp all right well I mean we got
left here all right you got three left
I'll read one more and then I'll read
two later all right
blue apron everybody blue apron it's
important I've never needed these people
more than I do right now have to eating
a [ __ ] doughnut it's important to
know where your food comes from for less
than $10 per person per meal blue apron
delivers seasonal recipes along with
pre-portioned ingredients to make
delicious home-cooked meals choose from
a variety of new recipes each week or
let blue aprons culinary team surprise
you recipes are not repeated within a
year so you'll never get bored upcoming
meals include aisle GZ gonna be eating
like a dictators wife you know they
never put on the same pair of shoes do
you think that fat guy in North Korea
lets his [ __ ] girlfriend kick him in
his balls hey hey and then afterwards he
walks up to all right and that's what
they do and then they feed their uncle
to the dogs and that my friends is North
Korea spicy shrimp and Korean rice cakes
with cabbage and furikake pork chops and
garlic piccata maybe that's what he
calls his dick
furikake that's his nickname for his
dick with scallion rice and spinach
mushroom and chipotle pepper and
enchiladas with lime sour cream
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences blue apron has
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment so you get the
deliveries only you want this is the
deal check out this week's menu and get
the first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron com / /
you will love how good it feels and
taste to create incredible home-cooked
meals with blue apron so don't wait
that's blue apron calm / / blue apron a
better way to cook and a great way to
stay in shape or get in shape all right
this is a quick one simply safe earlier
this month
consumer electron at the Consumer
Electronics Show it wrapped up in CES is
the incredible is this incredible
tradeshow what all the big tech company
unveiled their newest innovations it's
like seeing the future in front of your
eyes our sponsor simply safe home
security was there and they had one of
the most talked-about products at the
show did you hear the new simply safe
security camera the camera connects to
the sensors in your alarm system so if
an intruder tries to break in the camera
will automatically start recording
that's pretty dope huh
busted right do-do-do-do-do can't steal
this then not only will simply safe call
the police but you'll actually have
you'll actually have you'll have actual
evidence sorry so when the police arrive
you can say here's the guy Gary is right
there holy [ __ ] is that oj simpson
it's truly incredible plus was simply
safe you can check in at home anytime
anywhere just live stream HD footage
directly to your smartphone imagine if
it was your [ __ ] neighbor and you're
in like the Cayman Islands and it
[ __ ] goes to your phone and you had
the guy's number and you could [ __ ]
call them up after you called the cops
you call them up be like eh a rental or
involved James Simpson listen no not
dude no no no we're all good we're all
good you sound weird dude are you okay
you got a weird sound in your voice
yeah I'm still in the Cayman Islands
guess what buddy guess what I got simply
safe what is that it's the security
system that just filmed your [ __ ]
psycho ass breaking into my apartment
the cops are pulling up right now Oh
Jake huh
what do you got to say about that all
right if you want to see for yourself
what simply safes brilliant technology
can do for your home go to simply safer
comm you'll even get a special 10%
discount that simply safe Burt calm
simply spell s impl i safecom for a 10%
discount off your home security system
simply safe Burt calm I might as already
the last one and it's nice and quick it
stamps calm everybody do you still go to
the post office oh my god that's so 2012
you know something I use stamps calm any
time I'm you know anytime I'm selling
posters and I need you know [ __ ] myself
out at the end of the [ __ ] show I
want to shake some sweaty hands
you know look at some gray red wine
teeth that's what I do when I go out
there listen if I can figure it out so
can you
so if stamps can save time save you time
and money which you can use to grow your
business I can mail a letter any package
using just my computer and my and the
mailman comes and picks it up and it is
a man actually actually that's a wool
man the male wool man comes and picks it
up unlike the post-office stamps calm
never closes
you can print postage for letters or
packages at your convenience 24/7 seven
days a [ __ ] week it's convenient it's
easy it's reliable its flexible you know
like some chick that will bang you
without a relationship convenient easy
reliable inflexible no need to lease an
expensive postage meter right now you
can enjoy the stamps service with us you
have to [ __ ] itch right below your
ear right behind your jawbone and it
makes you want to cuff is that the
eustachian tube no need to lease an
expensive postage meter right now you
can enjoy you can enjoy stamp stamp
service with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage
and a digital scale without a long-term
commitment go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in bur that stamps comm enter
burst amps calm never go to the post
office again and guess what that's the
end of you guys listening to me read out
love well at least advertising was there
anything else I wanted to talk about
before I [ __ ] got into the goddamn oh
yeah you know something I'm gonna be in
San Jose if anybody knows a good
rehearsal space out there that has some
good sounding drums and I can maybe go
over there for a day or something like
that because I don't get the you know
I'm always on the practice pads here and
I miss playing drums and I'm learning
all this cool [ __ ] and you know the deal
man I'd love to get those [ __ ] be
drums it'd be nice if they hooked me up
with a free one and I could talk to my
listeners about how awesome they were
wink-wink nudge-nudge give me the
[ __ ] drums but you know playing on a
real kit that's the real deal you know I
love those electronic kits but the end
of the day they make you sound [ __ ]
amazing you're like am I the next John
Bonham I think
I am and then he get behind a real kid
you're like oh wait a minute I suck all
right donut shop while in San Jose hey
Bill I know you've been in San Jose I
know you'd be here coming up and I think
I know of a spot that's totally your
style
it's called Stan's Donuts I know you're
cutting the carbs and [ __ ] but goddamn
is it worth the extra elliptical time
just an old-school donut shop that's
been around for decades and hasn't
changed a bit
none of that crazy soy-based gluten-free
pomegranate fritter with cruelty free
bacon [ __ ] just the classics
chocolate maybe an old fashioned or
jelly-filled you [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm
trying to lose weight don't tell me
about this place
but holy [ __ ] the only one you need from
Stan's is the plain glazed doughnut I'm
gonna be there with Dee del ray oh he's
off sugar so he won't do it they will
give you a glazed doughnut so so fresh
it might burn your mouth if you aren't
careful and you can see them pulling
them out of their fryer just behind the
counter can't beat it dude my mom used
to take me here before school when I was
really little and I came back for the
first time in like 15 years the other
day and it's even better than I
remembered well you got a little child
sense-memory going on there oh my god
dude why you doing this to me
immediately thought of you and that you
liked the old school feel of the place
it's like five minutes from San Jose
improv make it happen
do it for Stan no God well I can tell
you that's definitely happening well you
know what I'm gonna do I'm gonna do a
tour of San Jose one of my city tours
we're definitely I'm gonna [ __ ] go
there I'm gonna end there eating a
[ __ ] doughnut don't maybe I'll start
there just hating myself all right
Redskins Redskins I'm sitting here
listening your podcast in the past month
past Monday and I'm thinking about the
Redskins keep the name change the mascot
change the mascot to a potato that's
[ __ ] hilarious but maybe that's not
intimidating you know what I mean
the Redskins tune of course the nickname
would be the hashbrowns but you know
what you know hash browns are delicious
that's [ __ ] hilarious I what you know
something that's actually [ __ ]
brilliant
so you still call them the Redskins you
changed the mashed potato Matt the
mascot the mashed potato the mascot to a
[ __ ] potato you know something that's
one of the most brilliant [ __ ] ideas
I think that's ever been [ __ ] sent in
God knows I've never said anything
better than that that's [ __ ]
brilliant
change it to a [ __ ] potato but then
what do you have on the side of your
helmet then you know what you do you
just go back to the old logo with the R
on the side in the feather hanging off
is the red skin like you peel the potato
you know that thing when people like
they peel and they go all the way around
in a circle it could be like that
great idea that right there that's a
funny [ __ ] I hope you're very
successful in life thank you for the
let's [ __ ] ham I didn't ever think of
that man I'm slipping as a comedian all
right the Great Barrier Reef by the way
did you hear Netflix is gonna switch
from the stars from five stars to thumbs
up thumbs down I don't know why would
you do that you know because I give you
know if it's just thumbs up thumbs down
it's just such a wide peanut butter and
jelly sandwich thumbs up gourmet meal on
the French Riviera watching the [ __ ]
from a yacht watching the [ __ ] the
end of a Formula One race in Monaco
thumbs up
The Godfather thumbs up meatballs
thumbs up do you know what I mean
drinking orange juice after brushing
your teeth
thumbs down Adolf Hitler thumbs down
I guess cuz they get the [ __ ] ratings
it doesn't matter but I mean I like it I
like it lets me know you know like okay
people like this how much do they like
this
I don't know Three Stooges thumbs up
Schindler's List thumbs up I mean it's
just a what does anything mean anything
after that
alright Great Barrier Reef hey Billy Boy
huge fan of the show thank you remember
you were talking about the Great Barrier
Reef a couple of weeks or months ago not
really sure anymore
too much Weed Man anyway I saw this on
the front page of the New York Times and
thought you would enjoy [ __ ] on
Australia some more I don't like
[ __ ] on Australia I was just
[ __ ] on that guy it basically says
that huge sections of the Great Barrier
Reef that stretch across hundreds of
mile were recently found dead and they
were killed by overheated saltwater I
know this is coming from a liberal paper
but I think it's pretty clear evidence
there is significant global warming
anyway
you fat a bowl of written peace [ __ ]
love the podcast and keep on keepin on
yeah I gotta be honest with you I don't
watch I don't read up on a lot of the
environmental stuff because it's too
[ __ ] depressing I love animals man I
love the earth me and I don't want to
see [ __ ] sea life dying and all that
[ __ ] I don't know I don't know what this
is just too many of us with it's just
like I think a plague is coming or I
actually think that the robots will be
in control of the upper one-percenters
and they will gradually take all of us
out and then what will be will each one
of those Illuminati guys will have their
own robot with all the answers I mean
it's a it's a [ __ ] it can play guitar
like Jimi Hendrix it can design the most
beautiful architecture it's the greatest
farmer they just whatever you need it to
[ __ ] do we can do so you'll never go
hungry
you'll always be entertained
and on top of that it'll be the best
looking chick you've ever seen in life
and you can [ __ ] its brains out I mean
right there if that's not going to be
the extinction of all the regular people
like like myself I think that that's
what's going to happen and then the
earth will gradually cool but all of our
deaths the Great Barrier Reef will come
back and the upper 1% will have what
they always wanted complete control but
I actually think they'll get bored after
a while you know there's nobody to
oppress there's nobody looked down on
you no that's actually a fascinating
[ __ ] movie would it be like there's
just no more challenge right and those
robots know how to like you know they
can like grow an ear in a petri dish
eventually you'll be able to grow all
vitals you know what I mean and then you
can just live forever
what would you do what would you do
there's a reason why you die you just
run out of [ __ ] what the [ __ ] would you
do I would just keep learning [ __ ] it's
like all right for the next 80 like
every 80 years you just picked being
something
all right this 80 years I'm gonna be a
gearhead I'm gonna learn how to take a
whole [ __ ] car apart put it back
together make it fast fast and loud I'll
just learn how to do that [ __ ] I'll have
the robot right here it knows everything
it'll [ __ ] teach me how to do it and
then once I get it down you know and I
do that for a while you know [ __ ]
learn every instrument learn every
language you're eventually just gonna
run out of [ __ ] to do you just be
looking at your robot just going like do
I know this is [ __ ] nuts I know we've
been together now sweetheart for [ __ ]
800 years but could you do me a favor do
you want me to kick you in the balls not
no sweetheart I don't it'd be funny if
they even though it looked totally
looked real and Tory felt like a real
person but they could never perfect the
voice so it's still [ __ ] talk like
that you are the best I've ever had
just like [ __ ] stop talking you're
killing it for me you'd have to just say
to the [ __ ] thing
look 800 years okay I'm coming up on 800
years
alright I've lived more years than Hank
Aaron hit homeruns could you do me a
favor on my 800th birthday I know what I
want okay could you just choke me to
death please not compute you know and
you just they won't kill you and then
you're [ __ ] your punishment is that
you live forever you know you kind of
like a vampire at that point cuz you can
kind of seduce any woman you want
because they're all gonna be you know
you're just gonna get but you know what
I bet after a while if you live long
enough you just start bang and you'd
have you make like ugly chick robots and
you just bang them because you were so
bit sick of bang intense I mean it's a
[ __ ] it's a hell of a goddamn it I
don't think human beings can survive in
that just you just think of all the [ __ ]
that that's gonna happen alright female
comedians what the [ __ ] is this I didn't
know this was coming up alright hey baby
daddy Billy Boy emailing from Dublin a
big fan of the podcast to stand-up I've
been watching a lot of stand-up specials
over the last month recently I'm making
a concentrated effort to watch female
comedians because all the comedians I'm
a fan of our men unfortunately I've
struggled to find many who meet the mark
I just watched so-and-so's Netflix
special which was hilarious okay then
I'm gonna say the name Kathleen Madigan
yes she's the [ __ ] real deal and
she's a total hot [ __ ] I love her she's
been [ __ ] crushing it since since I
started English comedian Joe brand was
also excellent although I don't know if
she's still active beyond all the others
I've seen
all the others I've been [ __ ] in my
opinion my issue with this disparity is
that I don't think men are funnier than
women in general the women in my life
like my girlfriend my sister and friends
are just as funny as my guy friends in
your experience would you find male
comedians funnier like myself if so why
do you believe this is the case could it
be the fact that the industry is so male
heavy our women comedians trying too
hard to emulate their male counterparts
these are all questions I can't answer
I don't [ __ ] it I don't know what the
deal is and it's all your opinion maybe
I'm just an ignorant prick but I feel
like there's a female perspective in
comedy that would speak to me that isn't
met by the better-known female comedians
either way thanks for the laughs
congrats to you and a lovely Nia on the
little baby bird go [ __ ] yourself I
don't know dude it's like you know you
know what it is I just think it's like
dance you're into a certain style of
music and the other [ __ ] doesn't speak
to you see don't you don't go to that
but every once in a while there's a band
you know oh [ __ ] I didn't think I like
country music I like this country music
I just think I don't know what the deal
is I don't know why there's so much of
that [ __ ] talk my [ __ ] is this okay
if you're [ __ ] funny you're funny if
you're not funny you're not funny okay
and it's not the crowds fault it's not
this it's not the [ __ ] Martians it's
you're not funny and one of the things
I've found with people male and female
who aren't funny is they [ __ ] got
every goddamn excuse in the book and I
just want to say hey just go on stage
and [ __ ] kill and all your problems
will be solved go on stage and [ __ ]
kill that's what it was
you know that's what it's always been if
you do that all of these [ __ ] issues
that everybody oh there's this over here
there's that over here there's a [ __ ]
liberal bias there's all of this it's
all [ __ ] [ __ ] if you go on stage
and you [ __ ] kill you're gonna get
work that's it
that's it so I don't I don't know
whatever I'm so [ __ ] sick of all all
of that you know our women funny our
blah blah blah and so just lump
everybody into a group I is more just
asked me do you think Kathleen Madigan
is funny just ask me that in that email
I think she's [ __ ] hilarious I love
her delivery and you know I love about
her she can just stand there and be
funny I got to jump around scream and
yell action out she can just stand there
and [ __ ] murder for an hour and you
know what's great too is you meet her
and she's totally down-to-earth and
she's [ __ ] awesome so there you go
that's the positive way of me getting
out of that type of [ __ ] cuz I'm not
walking into that like why the [ __ ] do
you think I would answer any of that
[ __ ] you know what I mean look what
business are you in okay why don't you
[ __ ] on some people and your [ __ ]
your [ __ ] arena I don't want to do
that that's cannibalistic oh my god I
mean there's just so many fun I do I
kind of like name funny female comics
for you is that what I got to [ __ ] do
now I got to do your [ __ ] homework
all right feeling in love with my best
with my lesbian best friend a Billy dad
bought uh Jesus yourself [ __ ] right
I'm a huge fan of all your [ __ ] why are
you calling it [ __ ]
I loved your new special I need some
advice I'm a young guy and I haven't
even tried to get into a relationship in
a few years because my last one turned
into a [ __ ] nightmare anyways over
the past year I've been hanging out with
this lesbian and we've grown close Wow
Jesus dude this is gonna this is the
ultimate this is the ultimate just
cold-case file dude you're chasing the
chasing leads that aren't even there
she's amazing and my best friend the
problem is I find myself growing more
and more attracted to her by the day
we've talked about having a threesome
well which makes me think she might want
to [ __ ] me but doesn't want to admit it
to herself
Oh strike everything that I just said
dude you you have [ __ ] walked into
paradise I am happy for you my friend
god bless you
god [ __ ] bless you I hope this
[ __ ] turns out the way I think it's
going to I'm so you just made the rest
of my day that someone's in this
situation right now lately she's been
trying to get me a girlfriend probably
so this sexual tension can be redirected
what the [ __ ] do I do bill please help
me and go [ __ ] yourself
what do I do dude I've never been in
this situation I'm living vicariously
through you what do you do don't [ __ ] it
up dude okay wait a minute
who's been in this situation and don't
[ __ ] lie to me send in what this guy
could do so he doesn't [ __ ] this up oh
dude god [ __ ] bless you what do you
do oh jesus what okay what the [ __ ]
would I do I don't know man I you know
what I would do I'd go out drinking with
her right and I would [ __ ] all right
pick somebody out who do you like you go
up you strike a conversation you know
what I mean maybe she strikes up the
conversation so the [ __ ] will the
other lady keeps their defensive shield
down you know okay this is what you do
dude you get into great [ __ ] shape
okay you gotta help out your lesbian
girlfriend okay you get yourself a new
[ __ ] wardrobe you got to look right
when you're going up you put on a pair
of [ __ ] me undies
okay you eat blue apron for a goddamn
month you shed some [ __ ] pounds you
put on some biondi's you dress [ __ ]
right
okay give you a lesbian friend something
to work with there any lesbians listen
to this [ __ ] podcast how does this go
down
maybe she knows hang on a second let me
hit pause you know what I realized you
know I realized she's gonna come in here
hold up my daughter and we we can't talk
about this [ __ ] when she's here all
right well I'm have to put this there
this one I can't do okay now it's you
who's who took a blow kiss she's never
gonna be on again now my daughter's
developing eventually she'll be playing
with toys she can sneak an errand she
can she can answer some goddamn
questions all right there you go
or I don't know how to do it anyway so
just I don't know what tell you dude I'm
so [ __ ] excited I can't even think
straight right now
god bless you I hope this [ __ ] works
out man and I I want I want to hear the
[ __ ] story okay lady she's been
trying to get me a girlfriend probably
so this sexual tension can be redirected
yeah uh you know so she's basically
every once in a while she doesn't mind
banging a guy as long as there's you
know you know what it's like it's like
you going out to a restaurant right
she's gonna order one thing you're gonna
wear the other thing but she's gonna
take a couple of [ __ ] you know a
couple spoonfuls off your plate that's
what's gonna happen here oh my god
[ __ ] tremendous [ __ ] tremendous
god bless you dude I have no advice I've
never been in that situation it's
tremendous all right good luck to you
all right everybody go [ __ ] yourselves
I'll talk to you on Thursday and I'll
check in on you on Thursday and thank
you to everybody my shows are sold out
in San Jose I'm doing two Monday to
Tuesday to Wednesday I'm working with
the great Dean del Rey we're gonna
[ __ ] kill it when we're up there and
also I need to hype this show I have
coming up I'm doing a [ __ ] we'll send
the link out on March 3rd where the [ __ ]
my god I'm doing this MS benefit and
they're honoring Richard Pryor and it's
on March 25th 7:00 p.m. out here in Los
Angeles I'll put up the link for tickets
and all that I believe we just tweeted
it out I'm gonna be co-hosting with
Craig Gass there's gonna be all these
amazing musicians there it's gonna be a
great night for a great cause I hope you
guys can make it down that's a Saturday
night come on come on down there's a
[ __ ] taco truck down there's gonna be
a great time all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves out
checking on you on Thursday